après qu'est ce qui se passe ils vont où
les papiers yvonne à la marelle is when
you're in loges albanais samaran déjà
bien rempli leurs sacs poubelles la
mission du jour nettoyer autour de
l'étang de beauregard des bénévoles sont
venus ramasser des déchets en tous
genres à la celle saint cloud ce
dimanche après midi
d'abord ça nous fait sortir ça fait voir
un petit peu la végétation la nature
et puis à profiter d'une activité toutes
les deux ensemble et je trouve que c'est
bien aussi pour initier aux bons gestes
écologiques pour apprendre un petit peu
aux enfants que c'est important de ne
pas jeter de déchets on est un peu
désoeuvrés par rapport aux abords des
milieux naturels qu'on peut traverser et
qui sont jonchées de détritus et voilà
c'est pas comme ça qu'on aimerait voir
ces lieux je trouve ça important que
chacun participe à son petit niveau à
l'entretien de notre planète et
notamment des forêts qui sont envahis de
plastique et de sacs et de et de
détritus et chaussons important que la
jeune génération soit aussi là à
l'initiative l'association forest
cleaning lancé en septembre 2020 par de
jeunes chinois elle compte à ce jour une
centaine de bénévoles
elle s'organise autour de trois missions
toutes les forêts bien sûr on doit les
nettoyer parce que si on ne nettoie pas
les forêts c'est vraiment les forêts
sont très très sale et c'est donc tous
les animaux meurent donc notre
association il a donc pour nettoyer les
forêts protéger les forêts et
sensibiliser les jeunes et les adultes à
ne plus jeter en forêt l'association
recherche des bénévoles pour les
accompagner lors de prochaines actions
et appellent aussi au doux les
fondateurs aimerait la développer dans
toute la france